it's time for true's news your good news
booze and the good news jakkus with me
at the desk my trusty co-pilot and human
cocktail rossi ross
[Applause]
you are you're as effervescent as the
most fine champagne there i've always
wanted to make a rose matthews that was
like you know extra bubbly and slightly
fruity you know
full-bodied i'm like that's so funny
when are we doing i know right you know
my business side can't just hear an idea
like that and like let it pass by extra
bubbly and a little fruity that's what
it should say on the bottle exactly
you've already got your campaign slogan
all right oh this just in we just hold
like a billion bottles thank you so much
thank you so much rightfully so well
first up we are all going back to the
movies again which is so
exciting and i have to say a lot of
people have asked me personally like
where did the rom-com go why are
rom-coms not around we need them so
listen to this
there is a rom-com on its way george
clooney and julia roberts in ticket to
paradise it's not out to the fall but
people reports that julia says it's the
rom-com script she's been waiting for
since the 90s you know that in the 90s i
mean she was making films like notting
hill my best friend's wedding um i mean
if anyone is an authority on rom-coms i
feel like it is julia roberts yeah julia
roberts and you yes
hello oh icon i i bow to her um and
george clooney hasn't done a rom-com
since he did one fine day with michelle
pfeiffer which i've seen 100 million
times thank you so much well julia says
that she wasn't avoiding rom-com she was
just waiting for that one that was good
enough and this is it and i will tell
you i would trust julia roberts as an
authority on rom-com so boy am i excited
i'm excited too and i love hearing the
behind the scenes of how it happens
because you speak from like the movie
star pov let me talk from the the fan
pov a little bit julia roberts i need
this movie all right i have
watched in the past how many years has
it been
i sit and i watch notting hill
pretending like i don't know exactly
what's gonna happen and that i can't
quote these guys i'm just a girl
standing in front of a boy asking right
you know how about my best friend's
wedding is there a better movie
all right next up here's a story you
actually brought to the desk drew it's
about the incredible billy eilish yes i
know we're all obsessed
she's been tearing up the stage at
coachella and veg news reports she's
also found time to collaborate with nike
this is the collaboration i did not see
coming they asked billy to give their
iconic air force one sneakers a
sustainably
a sustainable makeover right which means
make it more environmentally friendly
and check these out these mushroom
colored kicks are made entirely of vegan
leather and they're 100 recycled
polyester uh billy also designed a roomy
oversized sweatsuit to match would you
would you wear this drew well i'm so
excited to show you them
she is so capable of being a leader
and influencing her generation and the
fact that she is this person
and it's just time for all of us to
approach things differently there's just
no one i love more
than billy eilish and i'm so excited for
her to do this because i think this
could be the first of so much and this
is all made with vegan
leather um and that's all really
environmentally friendly because even
some vegan leathers are actually plastic
that don't break down this is not that
and i'm just so impressed with
everything she does so thank you for
bringing this and they're so cool
they're so cute
i love that she's changing the sneaker
game
she's changing the sneaker game at like
20 years old at 20 years old i was
saving up to buy a pair of sneakers you
know like
she's very impressive she really is on
every single level agreed she is just
incredible so thank you billy for
everything you do yes agreed
[Music]
you